بالظبط الذي لا يميز بين الولايات المتحده
واجرائي
عظيم هو الاكبر في التاريخ المعاصر فنحن
نشاطر قيما ومصالحه مشتركه
اهتمامات المشتركه الديمقراطيه ثاني
قويتان سوف تبقى
اؤكد لك ذلك
الجميع
وساعدتنا في التغلب على ازمات كثيره الامم
لان زيارتكم تاتي في وقت مهم للغايه في
وقت
نجد فيها ان اللاعبين كثر في الاسره
الدوليه يقف يرون بربريه النظام الايرانيه
ضد شعبه ويرون كيف يقوموا هذا النظام
بتصدير الاعمال الغدائيه خارج حدوده طيبه
المهم من اجل تحقيق هذا الهدف المشترك
بالاضافه الى هذه المخاطر التي تصادفنا
فلابد لنا من ان ننتهج الفرص فرص في
تعزيزي نطاق السلم
والتعميق السلام الذي ابررناه بموجبه
بموجب اتفاقيه ابراهام والمبادره التي
ايضا
هذه
مغزى مهم في مساعي لتحقيق الامن والازدهار
لهذا الجزء من العالم
بصوره
العربيه الاسرائيلي وهذا سوف يساعدنا على
التوصل الى حمض العملي
لكافه الجوار ارحب بكم مجددا في القدس
شكرا رئيس الوزراء يسعدني ان اراك مجددا
اود ان اشكركم على ما كان كما هو معتدل
هذا
كما فعلته عند وصول اسرائيل عبرته الى
رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيليه
السبعه الذين تعرضوا لقتل الارهابي في
مطلع هذا الاسبوع
وقال بان الولايات المتحده تقدم الدعم
الاسرائيلي وشعبها وهذه الرساله
الاسرائيلي يدكون ان الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه
75 سنه
معنا بين ايران يجب ان لا يسمح لها
وناقشنا تعميقي طبيعه العلاقات لمواجهه
والتصدي لانشطه ايران في المنطقه وما
بعدها يعني كما هو كما تقوم اسرائيل بدعم
هذا النظام الارهابي فهي تستخدم ايضا
المسير التي ترسله بروسيا لقتل الابرياء
الاوكرانيه
اخرى بين اسرائيل
يعني هذا الشهر وفد كبير من الحكومه من
بعض الحكومات من اسرائيل
والامارات والبحرين كانوا قد اجتمعوا ضمن
مجموعه العمل وهو التجمع الاكبر من نوعه
لبعض المسؤولين الاسرائيليين والعرب
الماضي هذه المجموعه تركزوا على بعض
القضايا التي تؤثر على حياته الشعوب ومن
اجل تعزيز الامن والصحه والتعلم
والسياحه وفي سياق الجهود المشتركه
للشباب فان رئيس الوزراء قد تحدث عن
الاشياء
مع المنطقه همم سنوات
منطقه من اجل التعاون والتعلم واجراء
البحوث والبدايه باطلاق الشركات الجديده
والتعامل في مجالات الزراعه
هو غيرها من القطاعات المختلفه كلها هذه
الامور من شانها ان ان تخلق المزيد من
الثقه وهذا لا يمكن ان يحدث دون قياده
رئيس الوزراء سوف نستمر
همم
ومازلنا نعتقد ان الفريق الامثل لتحقيق
هذا الامر من خلال الحفاظ على رؤيه
دولهتين
يبعدنا عن هذا نفسه سوف يعود باثر سلبيه
على همم على امن اسرائيل وعلى الدوله
اليهوديه الديمقراطيه لدى فانني اهيب
بكافه الاطراف ان تتخذ خطواتنا عاجلا من
اجل تحقيق الهدوء وتخفيض التصعيد والتحقق
من ان هناك بيئه مئاتيه يمكن انه من
خلالها ان اعمل ان نعمل على اعاده يحس
الامن في الفلسطينيين والاسرائيليون يجب
ان يتمتعوا
بهذه الدرجه من من لابد ايضا من العمل على
العيش المشترك حتى في القدس
عبر عن موقفه في هذا الخصوص من اهم خصال
هذه الشركه القويه في ما بينها
الرئيس الذين
مقربا من كافه
مساء الوزراء الاسرائيلين السابقين الذين
شاطروا رؤيتهم همم بصوره المشتركه
وعبر الطبيعي عبر هذه العلاقه المشتركه
بين بلدين نعود مجددا الى مساله ان اا ان
هذه العلاقه متاصله من حيث القيم المشتركه
وهذا يدعم مؤزرتنا لمؤسسات الديمقراطيه
وحقوق الانسان
والعداله
وحريه الصحافه المدنيه الذي يجب ان ينعم
به
شعبه البلدين
نسيبه يا جماعه العمل على تامين الدفاع عن
حقوق الاساسيه والتوافق ل اجماعا هذا قد
يكون هو سبيل الامثل لتامين وضمن كافه هذه
الحقوق وسوف يجعل من ديمقراطيه اكثر هذا
ما فعلته اسرائيل والولايات المتحده عبر
عقود من الزمن من خلال
الالتزام بالمبادئ التي رسمناها لانفسنا
وبكل صراحه ووضوح وكما يفعلوا الاصدقاء
عندما نتفق
يجب ان نلتزم بهذه المبادئه هل المناقشات
التي اجريتها مع رئيس الوزراء سوف تكون هي
نقطه البدايه وهي حلقه مستمره لمناقشه
المقبله من اجل العمل على التعزيز والدفاع
اعمده الديمقراطيه التي نلتزم بها مجددا
رئيس الوزراء اشكركم جزيلا على حسن
الضيافه وعلى هذه المحادثات الجيده
والشراك بين بلدينا
اذا مشاهدينا استمعنا الى المؤتمر الصحفي
لكل من وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه انطونيو
رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو